This is not the Confederate national flag.
When the US separated in two during the civil war, this was the flag that
His rebel side used: The Bonnie Blava, copied from the Republic of East Florida.
Not seriously This country existed: due to a border conflict between Spain and the USA
On the sale of Louisiana gave local rebels the opportunity to take control of a fort and in 1810, declare
independence, with the required flag and a functional government - for 78 days.
The US put an end to that.
Anyway, we move forward to the Civil War when Mississippi separated from the Union and
It adopted the flag of the small country that had been found within its borders. And it turned
On the unofficial flag of the revolt, but for a long time. Blue does not persuade
It's a Yankee color.
The new confederal government asked for proposals and received several.
Including those of a German-Prussian artist from Alabama who was possibly inspired
in the Austrian Empire. I in Betsy Ross.
(Note to the margin: since we speak of names with erroneous names, Betsy Ross probably did not design this one
flag - there is no evidence that you give credit to the legend, just stories long after you die.
In the style of Godiva maiden. But we are turning aside.)
The confederal government selected it as its official flag and called it
"Stars and Bars" - so to name this other stars and bars is bad for two reasons: it is not his name,
This is a cross. That's bars.
The new flag was adopted outside the war, but in the battlefield, the similarity with the flag of the Union
He was confused, along with all the terror and smoke.
However the Confederation followed the flag, but the army wanted to avoid fire friend
so he chose one of the rejected designs and made it a war flag.
Navy also liked the design and eventually also changed it, although using a lighter blue
and supposedly less Yankee.
The popularity of the official flag fell to the Confederation as time went by
(although the number of stars was increasing) while the popularity of the war flag grew.
So in 1863 the Confederate government again tried again, and chose the target by sticking the flag
of war to one corner.
This was "better" in the sense that the flag seemed less yankee, but "worse"
in which now the international symbol to surrender was in the background.
The army kept its design.
Two years later the Confederate government tried again, adding a red bar
and a new name "aggressive" (The blood-stained flag). In addition the new flag made the flag of war more rectangular.
So it could no longer be confused with the white flag and it was the last flag, since 36 days later
the confederacy surrendered.
So this design technically was never the flag of the allied government - but ...
close enough